[Musik]
30 stunden ist es her seit sich birgit
und jörg cent von ihrem liebsten in der
schweiz verabschiedet haben nun sind sie
endlich auf der philippinischen insel
palawan angekommen ihrem neuen zuhause
[Musik]
trotz der langen reise die sens sind in
bester stimmung
der schlaf ist ein geräumiger toyota
vierradantrieb york kaufte ihn als er
vor gut neun monaten zum ersten mal auf
palawan war
in der letzten folge von auf und davon
träumten die fans noch ihrer wohnung
birgit verabschiedete sich von ihren
kollegen und vollzog eine letzte
amtshandlung als schulleiterin der
abschied von ihren zwei kindern fehlt 11
weit schwerer als sie gedacht hatten
bertrand gille hatte seinen letzten
arbeitstag und rauchte eine letzte
zigarette
es war ein trauriger abschied von
monique us mutter
doch in der türkei erwartete sie das
türkisblaue meer
die fischers banken um ihr visum für
kanada und lösten ihren betrieb auf
[Musik]
und dann der schock ihr visum wurde
erneut zurückgewiesen
[Musik]
das zürcher ihr passen baut ein kleines
ferienressort amir bis sie dort
einziehen können haben sie in puerto
princesa der hauptstadt von paravan ein
häuschen gemietet
ihre neue angestellte der serie gegrüßt
sie
und die filipina ist komplett aus dem
häuschen
aber bis zum schlafen wunderbar
ventilator ich ja da
wir sagen dass man auch schlafen
bis es erste hit fertig
[Musik]
birgit scheint mit dem lokalen essen
mehr mühe zu haben
[Musik]
im türkischen aller starter haben zwei
schweizer große pläne sie brauchen ein
hotel doch zunächst stehen sie vor einer
ganz anderen herausforderung
sie wollen das rauchen aufgeben ein
nikotinpflaster soll helfen
in
zwei wochen nein nein
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja
monika bekommt schneller als erwartet
recht die erste wäsche trocknen ist sind
die sorgen
[Musik]
werthan ist aufgewühlt wegen eines
telefonanrufs von einem stein händler
bei ihm wollen sie natursteine für den
bau ihres hotels kaufen diese steine
aber sind sehr begehrt
aber wir haben keine anzahlung gemacht
macht deswegen sage ich hier es
funktioniert nicht wie ein schweizer war
der moment sehr geehrt für softies
machte kubicki den sie einfach gar
nichts gut da kannst du das sagen ja
du sagst du sagst ja ich würde
übersetzen sport ja
die natursteine für die hotelfassade
sind also weg doch vorerst gehen sie
nicht auf stein suche das bestimmt der
fahrer bert tanz schwager
ich weiß es nicht wir fahren einfach
schauen
wohin fahren wir halt geben wir zum
baustelle oder zumstein schauen oder wie
ok der schwager ist funktioniert und
spricht ein paar brocken deutsch
seit dem spatenstich vor zwei wochen
überwacht er den bau
doch etwas scheint ihm nicht aufgefallen
zu sein etwas was die bauherren monika
und wärtern sofort bemerken
[Applaus]
becker ist ziemlich hoch welcher werde
ziemlich hoch sein wenn ich sage der
kellner scheint zu tief zu sein
entsprechend sind die fenster zu hoch
gesetzt das wäre ein desaster denn im
keller ihres hotels wollen die beiden
künftig wohnen
[Musik]
wörtern konsultiert die baupläne auf
seinem handy
momentan sich dort beschäftigt wir sind
nicht so groß körperlich
[Musik]
in staufen im kanton aargau wo deine
familie mit ausdauer die fischers
seit drei jahren warten sie auf ein
visum für kanada 3 visums anträge sind
gescheitert vor kurzem haben sie den
vierten antrag gestellt
[Musik]
kurt fischer ist zimmermann und hat
bereits einen arbeitsvertrag in kanada
auch sein künftiger arbeitgeber braucht
seinen schweizer fachmann dringend wenn
nur endlich das visum käme
[Musik]
wieder kein visum und doch das ehepaar
ist felsenfest davon überzeugt das visum
wird in den nächsten tagen im
briefkasten liegen
[Musik]
damit sie dann möglichst schnell
aufbrechen können wollen sie bereits
jetzt ihr haus verkaufen
viel herzblut haben annett und kurt in
dieses haus gesteckt seit sie es vor
sieben jahren gekauft haben
[Musik]
damals hätten sie wohl kaum gedacht dass
sie das haus so schnell wieder verkaufen
würden
durch
den
[Musik]
open house funktionieren
es ist nicht nur das haus auch den
garten muss halt die gelernte gärtnerin
in fremde hände geben
gartenarbeit ist ihre leidenschaft das
700 quadratmeter große grundstück hat
sie zum blühen gebracht
mit dem erlös ihres hauses wollen sich
die fischers ihren kanada traum
finanzieren ein großes haus in der natur
mit viel viel umschwung
[Musik]
auf dem philippinischen palawan brechen
die sens auf nach bindung an
dort bauen sie ihre feriensiedlung die
fahrt geht richtung norden auf der
einzigen hauptstraße der insel
jörg kennt den weg genau als das paar
vor einigen monaten hier auf
grundstückssuche war musste birgit
früher zurückreisen jörg blieb entdeckte
das landstück und kaufte es heute sieht
es birgit zum aller ersten mal
[Applaus]
der mann starb
hier entsteht die zukunft des ehepaars
senden aus opfikon ein ferien resort mit
sechs kleinen häuschen einer restaurant
und eine bar
desiree ihre angestellte hat eine
überraschung für die beiden auswanderer
konnte im finger sollte ich wohl besser
nicht hinhalten
den traum hat die siri möglich gemacht
hätte ich gern hat die und die spannung
für sich die einzig das ziel gebracht
hat und nicht ungefährlich bis gesucht
wo wir uns das leisten also also otto
normalverdiener wo
sowas war mich und für die biene ist
einzige asiatische land wo
aus zwei die leute brauchen
das erste häuschen bauen sie in
traditionellen stil aus holz und bambus
das holz ist gebraucht und stammt von
abbruchhäusern das ist ökologischer und
billiger ein bereich jedoch muss
unbedingt gemauert werden
und nicht dafür ihr mann jörg
[Musik]
in der türkei wird noch immer heftig
diskutiert der keller schein tiefer als
geplant zu sein wer dann will es genau
wissen und stellt seinen bauleiter zur
rede auch monika ist beunruhigt denn im
keller will das paar zu künftig wohnen
mal ein wert an schwester versucht sie
zu beschwichtigen
genau alles wenn fertig stellen ist es
sehen können so sieht komisch aus man
kann es nicht vorstellen wie es ist 12
20 meter würde das noch nach oben kommen
weil da würde man noch eine schicht mehr
arbeiten so kann man ist dann ist es
okay aber wenn man jetzt finde ich den
keller sehr hoch war wie du sagst wenn
der wurde noch nicht fertig ist kommt
noch
sagt es gibt ein problem
mit einem zusätzlichen boden sollte das
problem eigentlich gelöst werden doch
wer dann hat die diskussion arg
zugesetzt
auch monika hat aufgehört zu rauchen
doch sie hat sich besser im griff als
ihr ehemann
[Musik]
doch der kaffee muss warten zuerst muss
sich das paar um die steine für die
fassade des hotels kümmern
in aller karte wird viel gebaut dennoch
soll das dorf seinen ursprünglichen
charakter behalten viele verbauen
deshalb die typischen natursteine aus
der region
[Musik]
noch begehrter sind die gebrauchten
natursteine
steine von abbruchhäusern
diese sind drei mal teurer als neue
steine
[Musik]
dreimal mehr bezahlen für secondhand
steine für monika ist das trotzdem ein
muss
rein optisch
die neuestes buch et hindernis orf nach
die wand und die alter stetig bildet den
wirklich nicht
der hauptgrund
dieser haufen hier wäre ein guter anfang
das paar aber braucht vier lastwagen
voll
[Musik]
der briefkasten der fischers in staufen
ist zwar leer geblieben aber
von der kanadischen botschaft kam eine
frohe nachricht
[Musik]
bleibtreu ist cool aber geistig zauber
hat
das visum kam per e mail ein
unscheinbares schreiben dessen
eigentlichen inhalt kurz fast übersehen
hätte
dallas er dass die einwanderungsbehörde
streike dass sich somit visa-anträge
weiter verzögern würden
denn hätte gemacht
im
moment überhaupt
nach drei jahren langem warten können
die fischers endlich aufbrechen
[Musik]
lizenz zogen aus mit 50 noch einmal ein
großes abenteuer zu wagen zuerst aber
wartete alltag
dagegen gehabt
dank
des starken yen hat es muss nicht
dann muss es so zu so zu so
lustig nein das wäre nur
zu
genau es ist wie zu auch genau vor mir
wir haben sie doch wahrscheinlich 1
millionen zu ja das werde ich nicht
nun kann jörg die flasche austauschen
ging
mit 1 0 durch
wer geht bleibt mit zurück während jörg
ins zentrum der stadt brauchst am
chaotischen straßenverkehr hat er seinen
spaß
für mich ein spiel mehr wo lassen sich
ohne emotionen
biogas ist
dass wir wissen dass das jedem aber wie
kaufberater de france
unternehmen die hier auch muss
umso glücklicher ist irgendwie anders
zusammengestellt das wenig
[Musik]
jetzt gilt es ernst die familie fischer
verabschiedet sich von annes bruder und
ihrer mutter
lange haben die fischers auf diesen
moment gewartet
als sie endlich das visum erhielten
hätten sie es am liebsten der ganzen
welt erzählt abschied nehmen sie nun
still und leise
[Musik]
über 8000 kilometer entfernt im westen
kanadas liegt die neue heimat der
fischers
[Musik]
ja er hinzu
hans
rath r und eigentlich hätte für
die wirklichkeit wird die fischers bald
einholen die familie hat ein gedrängtes
programm
[Musik]
denn
ich würde gerne baklava kaufen wo finde
ich die
gleich da vorne hat es eine konditorei
wackler war ist ein türkisches ihr
monika versucht sich möglichst schnell
an das lokale leben anzupassen wie
leicht es jedoch missverständnisse geben
kann erlebte die 41-jährige mit dem
bauleiter
doch letztendlich ist alles halb so
schlimm mit erfindergeist bekommt der
kenner die gewünschte höhe
männer machen
die butler war von monika ist als
nachtisch eines festlichen essens
gedacht
[Musik]
wer tanz schwester nahm kocht den
hauptgang sie führt monika so in die
türkische küche ein
mal an und wörtern verbrachten einen
teil ihrer jugend in deutschland
für ein paar wochen nun leben nagern und
ihr ehemann mit den auswanderern unter
einem dach
kocht ein bisschen praktisch immer als
sie sie reiben wir mal freunden oder
familie sorgt aber mehrheit das immer
noch nur
32 danach wie umgewöhnen
den gebratenen fisch einen bonito haben
die frauen perfekt hinbekommen jetzt
wird sich weisen ob monika im dorf die
perfekte baklava gefunden hat
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
kaum in kanada angekommen sind die
fischers eigentlich schon unter druck
sie haben noch keine dauerhafte bleibe
etwas um das sie sich noch kümmern
müssen
[Musik]
trotzdem nehmen sich die eltern die zeit
um ihren kindern das meer zu zeigen sie
fahren nach white rock die junge familie
ist ausgewandert weil es ihnen in der
schweiz zu eng wurde sie suchen das
ursprüngliche die weite die unberührte
natur
[Musik]
die
beiden
haben sich die wäsche bohne
der ausflug ans meer ist für den
sechsjährigen pauli und für seine
kleinere schwester kristin ein großer
spaß
also nix mehr menschen fremd oder
männlich sind aber schön wenn du
hast du's argument tor ist das einfacher
wieder weiter in die schweiz
und kone
und es klang
dass die meere
ja
[Musik]
seit einigen tagen wohnen die sens auf
palawan eigentlich sind die beiden
spontan und unkompliziert
doch wenn es wichtig ist gehen sie
planmäßig vor die zwei haben vieles zu
erledigen und fahren ins zentrum von
murdoch in china
bräuche
erster stopp die wäscherei noch hat das
paar keine eigene waschmaschine
es gab noch keine auflagen sind es nur
noch viele kinder sind
jetzt da
auf dem chinesischen markt wie sich jörg
der ehemalige informatiker neu
einkleiden
damit der schöne muster
nächster halt die haushaltsabteilung
eines großen kaufhauses
es war ganz groß mit uhse mit telefon
und asche und mütter leidige problem ist
es wesentlich dass
der wichtigste stopp jedoch ist beim
elektro fachgeschäft
fraglich ob alte post von der störung
aufziehen
die arbeiter auf ihrer baustelle
brauchen dringend verlängerungskabel für
ihre maschinen
jetzt ist er ein armer mann
ich trage es ihnen hinaus
mit dem auto bringen sie die einkäufe
nach bindung an wo ihr ferien resort am
entstehen ist
die sens setzen alles daran dass es mit
dem bau so schnell wie möglich vorwärts
geht zurzeit haben sie kein einkommen
das ganze projekt und ihre lebenskosten
finanzieren sie mit erspartem und
pensionskassengelder
in gut fünf monaten wollen sie ihre
ersten zahlenden gäste begrüßen
desiree das mädchen für alles zählt die
wildnis
wohin soll ich mit dem kabel
desiree hat auch den überblick sie weiß
wohin das kabel soll
damit birgit und jörg dieses land kaufen
konnten gründeten sie mit einheimischen
eine firma 60 prozent der firma aber
müssten viel kinos besitzen
[Musik]
110000 franken bezahlten sie für das
fast fußballfeldgroße landstück jetzt
kommen noch die baukosten dazu
drei millionen
alles in allem kostet ihr paradies unter
palmen rund 200000 franken
[Musik]
und du möchtest du auch einen hund haben
charmant die leute nehmen dem hund und
ein jahr später dass es auf den straßen
[Musik]
momentan zählt auch bert an makro und es
ihr doch wegen der hotelgäste möchte er
keinen eigenen halten
es ist ruhig geworden ihn als hatte die
hauptsaison ist vorbei die feriengäste
die im sommer zu tausenden durch das
dorf flanieren sind abgereist
dass die beiden in aller starter
gelandet sind ist hauptsächlich wegen
monika
das machen wir nicht viel wert da ist es
und wir zeigen ihnen auch sehr gut
gefallen aber nicht so gemacht wie die
ja nicht das habe ich immer gesagt bei
mir hat ist nicht auf einmal ok ich
schon schönes platz strände sind
wirklich sehr schön lars klares wasser
weiß ich nicht
eigentlich wäre es nicht schlecht wenn
es mehr grün geben hätte umgebung mal
mehr sieht man stein und ist es sogar
fertig werde ich
[Musik]
die heimat verdienst doch sehen ja schon
aber schweiz
ob erste oder zweite heimat heute wollen
sie feiern ein händler hat ihnen
natursteine zugesagt definitiv
neues heftig morgen werden wir zusammen
mit den zum baustelle
dann können wir mal richtig
mit
[Musik]
die familie fischer ist auf der suche
nach einem dach über dem kopf einen
camper bis sie in ihrem neuen wohnort
williams lake ein haus gekauft haben
richten sie sich in einem mobilen zu
hause ein
haben sie schon ein paar kemper
angeschaut
nein das ist der erste
die vierköpfige familie muss vielleicht
monate in einem solchen kemper wohnen
werden sie für eine gewisse zeit
hierbleiben
ich habe einen job in williams lake wir
sind ausgewandert
in nur einem nachmittag wollen die
fischers einen camper samt auto kaufen
obwohl beides aus zweiter hand ist geht
es um viel geld
die kinder beule und christin testen die
spielmöglichkeiten rund um ein zuhause
auf vier rädern aus und ihre mutter
macht sich gedanken übers geld
[Musik]
dieser kemper scheint der richtige zu
sein baujahr 2005 schon ein bisschen
älter aber sehr geräumig und er macht
einen gepflegten eindruck
[Musik]
dafür schon sowie tun
zu haben
[Musik]
das
versicherungsamt nummernschild in kanada
verkauft der händler alles in einem
paket
[Musik]
da habe ich hier
und heute
muss es genau sein
ok
63.000 dollar haben die fischers an
einem nachmittag ausgegeben für ein auto
und für einen ziemlich langen kemper
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
übernachten die fischers zum ersten mal
in ihrem neuen zuhause auf rädern der
familienalltag beginnt
[Musik]
und sie besuchen den neuen arbeitsplatz
von kurt über lärm slate
mit hund sack und pack ziehen die sense
in ihr ressort am meer das wird gefeiert
[Musik]
doch duschen können sie noch nicht
monika und wärtern müssen zum einkaufen
nach istanbul reisen dabei machen sie
einen besuch bei burtons eltern
[Musik]
wichtige wege mit träumen
ist ok
[Musik]